- Now, you say that achieving good sleep
starts even before bedtime.
Enlighten me.
- So, I always think
about sleep as like an on,
it's not an on/off switch,
it's more like a dimmer switch.
So doing a wind-down
routine, ideally an hour,
but most of us don't have an hour.
So start with five minutes of relaxation,
whatever you find is quieting,
just do it for five minutes,
then move to 10 minutes,
and really try to set that stage.
And the other thing I also would argue
is that a good bedtime comes
with a good morning time.
So if you're consistent
with the morning wake up-time every day,
you get bright light, you move,
you have a big glass of water,
that actually helps to set your bedtime
so you fall asleep a
little bit better as well.
(bright music)
♪ Oh, oh, oh ♪